[Musique]
on est en paix c'est silencieux ces
calmes c'est beau
[Musique]
de création
studio marchand je suis très fier qu'il
habite aussi
c'est l'endroit où je me sens bien juste
de chanter de d'avoir du plaisir
Florent volant
Mathieu mekenze
trois générations iNous de WhatsApp
malietenam trois chanteurs qui dans ce
studio fondé par Florent volant il y a
25 ans font vivre la musique autochtone
du Québec son fils Mathieu est aussi
producteur à sait jamais porté aussi
bien caler maintenant tous les astres
sont en ligne pour aller de l'avant puis
partager ce qu'on a de bons des deux
côtés quand tu peux québécois tant des
peuples de autochtone
[Musique]
Picard est l'un des chanteurs les plus
en vus de la relève autochtone
le nom toctones sont vraiment intéressés
je pensais au début c'est comme ça
mais vraiment elles sont intéressés
[Musique]
ils viennent me voir après les choses
c'est vraiment un bon ce que tu fais
même si on comprend pas vraiment ce que
tu dis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais il a beau gagner des prix et être
acclamé dans les festivals comme l'été
dernier aux francophonie de Montréal les
chansons de scottient Picard sont quasi
absentes des radios commerciales
c'est sûr que c'est injuste parce que
nous aussi on est là puis c'est dans le
temps et avec Ashton puis les autres ils
pensaient à Radio
Laurent volant faisait partie du duo
casting qui a cartonné dans les années
80 on connaît l'histoire c'est depuis la
crise d'aucuns 90 quand que casten a été
retiré des autres c'est jamais revenu
moi je me rappelle j'avais à l'époque
j'avais 12-13 ans puis j'entendais du
Castel c'est quoi la musique autochtone
a été complètement retirée des hôtes des
radios commerciales 30 ans plus tard il
s'apprête à demander au CRTC des quotas
de musées autochtones dont nos radio
mettez-vous donnez-nous nos choix
musicaux dans votre menu puis laissez
les gens aller vers ça moi je me le fais
dire toute l'année ce qui vous ont c'est
bon ce que vous faites on vous connaît
pas avoir un Kotor 5% pourquoi pas c'est
nos langues sont millénaires je pense
qu'on mérite d'avoir cette place là on
vient nous voir on vient nous entendre
puis on aimerait ça y
vous avez oublié quelqu'un vous avez dit
pourcentages mais vous avez pas de
pourcentage autochtone c'est ce qui fait
que on travaille fort breaking
mais aujourd'hui Florent volant laisse
le militantisme au plus jeune terrassé
par un AVC en 2021 il se remet peu à peu
et travaille à son rythme sur un nouvel
album c'est un nom maintenant de porter
ça moi
j'ai peut-être une petite charge de plus
que les autres je dirais mais je le fais
avec
[Musique]
Émile Bilodeau est un des jeunes auteurs
compositeur interprète québécois qui
s'impliquent auprès des Inno de washi
autochtone
il donnera un spectacle là-bas pour une
troisième année consécutive cet été il
adore aller au studio macoucham c'est
l'environnement que Florent et c'est
descendants ont réussi à créer cet
environnement là de partage puis d'amour
aussi d'amitié de fraternité
challenge ou si toi tu es dans ce que tu
connais puis je pense que c'est sacré
cette envie-là d'aller les voir
ou de notre autochtone c'est juste une
question de musique typiquement on est
fraternel là-dedans puis on est on est
fier de
cet esprit qu'on entretient
la musique pour unifier les peuples pour
ouvrir des fenêtres sur les communautés
ce sont des artistes uniques parce que
ils chantent dans leur langue
ils ont envie de nous parler de leur
culture ils ont envie que les gens
viennent les visiter un outil
[Musique]
Émile Bilodeau espère que le CRTC
répondra positivement à la demande de
Mathieu l'eau qu'on va chercher le plus
de revenus nous les créateurs c'est avec
les radios je pense que le passé 5% de
contenu de créateurs créatrices
autochtone ça peut être un bon début si
j'avais pas eu la radio au début de ma
carrière j'aurais pas pu comme prendre
plus de gens dans mon bande j'aurais pas
pu commencer à investir dans un marché
européen mais c'est d'abord au Québec
que Florent et Mathieu espèrent voir
leur culture rayonnée ils croient en
leur réussite les astres pensent-il S
sont alignés la relève
[Musique]
je dis merci à tous ces gens là qui
prennent le temps de nous écouter
aujourd'hui je vois moi une lumière le
vrai el rapprochement je le vois venir
[Musique]